Also man schreibt eigentlich so Sätze, so Hauptsätze mit Subjekt, Prädikat, Objekt. Manchmal lässt man eine Stelle von diesem Satz leer und dann ist da eine Variable drin und sagt, füll das bitte ein. Und so kann ich meine Abfragen halt formulieren.
Okay, also könntest du jetzt quasi sowas machen, nenne mir die Bürgermeister aller Hauptstädte, die größer als 190 Zentimeter sind?
Ja, das wäre kein Problem. Ich hab einen Triple Hauptstadt hat Regierungsoberhaupt, diesen Bürgermeister, diese Person, was dann eine Variable wäre. Du hast nach Hauptstädten gefragt, oder?
Nach Bürgermeister von Hauptstädten, die größer als 190 Zentimeter sind.
Genau, dann muss ich auch noch suchen, dass es ein Land gibt, dass dieselbe Stadt auch als Hauptstadt hat, das nicht eine beliebige Stadt ist. Und dann würde ich noch von dem Bürgermeister die Größe suchen, was auch ein Trippel ist. Bürgermeister hat Größe so und so wie Zentimeter. Und dann kann ich ihn noch einschränken.
Ich beginne zu verstehen, warum das eine Belastung für ein System sein kann. Weil man muss sich immer alles angucken eigentlich, oder? Also es geht vielleicht noch schnell herauszufinden, welche Städte Hauptstädte sind, aber dann muss ich wirklich alle. Und dann nochmal bei allen. Okay, verstehe. Okay, zwei Fragen in völlig gegensätzliche Richtung. Die erste. Was ist das Absurdeste, was ihr mit Wikidata jemals rausgefunden habt?
Dass Hello Kitty fünf Äpfel hoch ist, ist glaube ich ein gutes Kandidat. Ist tatsächlich eingetragen mit Apfel als Einheit. Was natürlich vorgesehen ist, das fällt für, in dem Fall wären es jetzt Zentimeter oder Meter, aber man kann auch Äpfel als Höhe eingeben und irgendwo steht es offenbar drin. Die Schlümpfe sind glaube ich drei Äpfel hoch oder so. Das haben französische Leute, haben das alle sofort erraten können und ich hab davon nie gehört.
Wie kommt man darauf, da sowas nachzufragen?
Ich glaube in dem Fall war ich neugierig, was Leute als Einheiten verwenden und hab geschaut nach allen Einheiten, die nicht tatsächlich physikalische Einheiten sind und dann kam das raus und noch irgendwelche andere Quatschen, die ich mich nicht mehr so erinnern kann.
So richtig absurd ist das alles nicht. Das ist halt überraschend oder manchmal auch einfach interessant.
Okay, überraschend ist es interessant. Nenne einen, wähle einen beliebigen Superleaf. Oder wie froh, wenn ich jetzt als Parkel abfrage?
Was ich gemacht habe, was ich immer gerne erzähle, weil ich so stolz drauf bin, ich hab mir einfach eine Karte geplottet bei Wikidata, bei der Abfragesprache hast du auch die Möglichkeit, dir Daten visualisieren zu lassen. Du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, gib mir die Geodaten dann auch als Karte aus, als Open-Street-Map-Karte und dann hab ich gesagt, ich hab eine Vermutung, wo in Deutschland die meisten Ortschaften sind, die auf OW oder ITZ enden. Ich vermute so ungefähr, wo das sein könnte, aber ich möchte das mal geplottet haben. Und tatsächlich kamen dann die Umrisse der ehemaligen DDR raus. Fast alle Städte, die mit OW oder ITZ am Ende sind, liegen im Osten. Es gibt ein paar Ausreißer, aber ja.
Also es gibt so viele Dinge. Aber was ich am interessantesten fand, war die Tatsache, dass offenbar vor einer ganzen Weile mal Baumsamen um den Mond geschickt wurden. Aus diesen Baumsamen wurden dann Bäume gepflanzt, die in Wikidata sind, weil es darüber Wikipedia-Artikel gibt. Und die kann man sich dann natürlich auch auf einer Karte anzeigen lassen.
Also zeige mir alle Bäume aus Mond, Baumsamen auf einer Karte ausgedruckt? Hat eigentlich aus dem Publikum hier vielleicht jemand eine Frage, die er mal stellen wollte oder sich noch nie zu stellen getraut hat? Oder wir hätten jetzt hier Programmierer an der Hand, die das einfach so... Na gut, ihr könnt es ja noch überlegen. Aber andersrum muss man sagen, das ist voll gut, um so Anekdoten zu erzählen, um genau so ein Ding zu machen. Ich kann mir auch tatsächlich vorstellen, mich vor den Rechnen zu setzen und einem abendlang zu überlegen, was für Quatsch ich jetzt rausfinden kann. Die Schuhfarbe von Bürgermeistern oder sowas. Ich bin so auf Bürgermeister geprimed, weil ich die ganze Zeit von Bürgermeistern geredet habe. Aber was ist denn jetzt, um das böse Wort mal zu sagen, die praktische Relevanz des Ganzen?
Die praktische Relevanz des Ganzen liegt zum Beispiel im Datenschonalismus. Wir erinnern uns vielleicht noch an die Panama Paper, wo man dann schnell mal eine Abfrage schreiben kann, die Menschen, die in den Panama Papers genannt werden, was haben die denn so für Berufe? Was sind denn die häufigsten Berufe dieser Menschen? Und da sieht man zum Beispiel, dass das Sportler sind, Juristen und so weiter.
Braucht man dazu Wikidata?
Da hast du dann quasi so eine Infografik, die quasi rausfällt. Also die Daten sind da und du kannst eine Abfrage machen, mit zwei Relationen, wurde erwähnt in den Panama Papers, und welcher Beruf ist das? Und stell mir das als schöne Bubbles dar. So hab ich dann halt datenjournalistisch erstmal eine Aufbereitung. Es hat jemand...
Aber jetzt ohne disputierlich klingen zu wollen, das ist ja was zu sagen, wenn man sich mit so was in den Panama Papers beschäftigt, wie ich sagen will, da klingt das so wie nach, okay, das ist ein effizienter Weg, aber das ist nichts, was ich nicht auch von einem anderen Weg hätte rausfinden können.
Genau, also viele Redaktionen oder so werden sicherlich dann irgendwie ihre anderen Quellen haben, werden Daten zum Teil auch einkaufen oder so, oder haben Leute, die dann halt schöne Infografiken produzieren. Bei uns ist es dann so, dass es halt wirklich jeder auch und jede machen kann. Und das ist halt das Wissen der Menschheit für alle verfügbar.
Aber das ist ja auch ein reteratter Punkt. Wikidata ist nicht nur dazu da, um Dinge rauszufinden, die ich anders gar nicht rausfinden kann, sondern ist auch dazu da, um Wissen breiter zugänglich zu machen.
Richtig, also diese ganzen, was weiß ich, künstlichen Intelligenzen oder Assistenten oder was es gibt, denen kann ich heute Fragen stellen und dann geben sie mir irgendwelche Antworten. Aber das sind halt irgendwie eingemauerte Wissenskönigreiche. Und ich mach mir da persönlich echt große Sorgen. Also es gibt halt einerseits das Web, was wir jetzt durchlesen, aber es gibt halt darunter noch dieses tiefere, dieses Datenweb. Und wenn ich eine Anfrage an Siri oder an Alexa stelle oder so, dann bewege ich mich nicht mehr im offenen freien Web, sondern bewege ich mich im Königreich Google oder im Königreich Apple. Und die haben diese Daten dann auch unter Verschluss. Mit Wikidata habe ich erstmal so eine Möglichkeit, dass ich so eine Daten- und Wissensbasis, wo ich beliebige KI Assistenzprogramme, sonst was, drauf aufsetzen kann, die für alle frei verfügbar sind. Und das ist für mich ganz, ganz essentiell, dass ich ein freies Betriebssystem habe, auch wenn ich es nicht benutze, aber dann, dass es zur Verfügung steht, dass ein freier Browser zur Verfügung steht, dass eine freie Wissensquelle wie Wikipedia zur Verfügung steht und dass auch freie Daten wie in Wikidata jetzt allen zur Verfügung stehen.
Was mir jetzt gerade freut, ist, ihr habt es am Anfang zwar gesagt oder du, Jens, dass du das nicht so bevorzugen würdest, wenn das Wikidata oder so eine semantische Aufarbeitung durch Algorithmen oder Key wiederum erfolgt, aber ich frage mich jetzt gerade, wenn man dieses Ziel erreichen will, was du gerade beschrieben hast mit dem, wir wollen das Wissen der Welt wirklich zugänglich machen, aber gleichzeitig das Problem haben, dass wir darauf angewiesen sind, dass Leute das machen und diese unter Umständen sozusagen sehr spezifisch und fokussierte Interessen haben, ist das auch Teil des Projektes, dass man sozusagen drüber nachdenkt, wie man diese Verbindungen, diese Strukturen sozusagen auch automatisiert vielleicht schneller machen kann? Oder ist das uninteressant?
Das ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Aber dadurch, dass die Daten in Wikidata strukturiert vorliegen, kann man halt zum Beispiel sagen, ok, unsere Daten sehen im Moment so aus. Wir haben Datensätze zu so und so viel Prozent Männern und so und so viel Prozent Frauen. Dieses Verhältnis gefällt uns nicht. Allein zu wissen, dass dieses Verhältnis so ist, ist in Wikidata wesentlich einfacher herauszufinden als zum Beispiel in der Wikipedia. Und das sichtbar zu machen und dann zu Leuten zu gehen, denen das bestimmte Thema am Herzen liegt und die sich dafür einsetzen. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Weg, wie wir daran arbeiten.
Was ich meine, das Problem gäbe es ja nicht, wenn man nicht auf Menschen angewiesen wäre, sondern wenn man auch daran arbeitet, dass man sagt, wir wollen Wikidata in Zukunft auch automatisiert befüllen.
Das wird auch gemacht zum großen Teil. Etwa 75% aller Edits in Wikidata sind nicht von Menschen, sondern von Programmen, die Menschen geschrieben haben. Also da arbeiten Roboter und Menschen Hand und Hand. Aber auch diese Programme werden von irgendjemanden geschrieben. Aber wenn jemand, was weiß ich, eine DVD mit statistischen Daten aus China hat, der wird sich dann nicht hinsetzen und die Einzelnen in Wikidata eintippen, sondern der wird ein Pysonscript schreiben, was diese Daten hochlädt, zum Beispiel.
Und der zweite Punkt, der zu beachten ist, ist natürlich, dass die Datensätze, wo man das herbekommen kann, auch nicht aus dem Himmel fallen, sondern die hat auch irgendjemand erstellt, mit seinem persönlichen Bias, mit seinem begrenzten Wissen, mit seinen begrenzten Möglichkeiten. Deshalb selbst, wenn man Wikidata nur mit Maschinen befüllt, hat man trotzdem noch nicht das gesamte Wissen der Menschheit.
Okay, aber zurück zu dem Sparkle-Ding. Was mir noch interessiert, ist, wie zugänglich das ist. Lukas, du hast ja erzählt, du arbeitest jetzt damit oder arbeitest auch daran. Wie bist du dazu gekommen und was ist der Stand da jetzt? Das soll eigentlich, also großes Ziel ja, da kann jeder darauf zugreifen.
Also ich bin dazu gekommen, indem ich Queries, die andere Leute geschrieben haben, angefangen habe zu lesen und dann irgendwann versucht habe, ein bisschen zu bearbeiten. Und hab dann, bin dann praktisch irgendwann dazu gekommen, dass wir selber beizubringen, diese Abfragesprache. Ist aber natürlich nicht so, dass es von jetzt auf sofort geht und dass jeder dafür die Zeit hat, das zu lernen. Wir müssen schon daran arbeiten, das für die Leute zugänglich zu machen, auch wenn sie nicht die Zeit haben, jetzt in Sparkle einzusteigen. Und wir haben eine Seite, wo man fragen kann, ich hätte gerne diese Query, kannst du mir das schreiben? Und dann antwortet meistens jemand, aber es skaliert ja auch nicht. Wir arbeiten schon auch an Systemen, wo sich Leute einfacher ihre Abfragen praktisch schon zusammenklicken können. Also wir haben einen anderen Praktikant, Werkstudent, nämlich sicher, bei Wikimedia, der daran arbeitet, hauptsächlich mit Fokus auf Listen-Generierung, dass da Wikipedia-Autoren auch solche Queries generieren können, ohne jemals das Sparkle, das da letztlich runter liegt, sehen zu müssen. Dass es für die einfacher zu bedienen wird.
Im Moment ist es halt alles noch eine große Nerd-Angelegenheit. Und naja, sind halt alle Nerds, wie wir hier sitzen. Auch du, Marcus?
Ich habe da meine Zweifel manchmal, aber gut.
Ja, aber klar, es ist halt im Moment schon beeindruckend, aber es ist irgendwie wie ein Auto, wo die Karosserie noch fehlt. Und man sieht, der Motor ist schon super. Aber wir haben ja noch ein paar Jahre.
Es fährt aber noch nicht ungefährlich.
Genau, und Kfz-Mechanikerkenntnisse sind notwendig für den Ausdruck.
Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber geredet, und das war auch die ursprüngliche Motivation, dass man mit dem Wissen, was man in der Wikipedia ansammelt, nicht nur Menschen lesen kann, sondern auch einen breiteren algorithmisierten und datensucherischen Zugang hat. Aber könnte man denken, das ganze Ding kann man ja vielleicht auch mit anderen Sachen machen. Gibt es da Pläne, oder ist das tatsächlich, weil Wikimedia kümmert sich um die Wikipedia, deswegen ist das Wikidata auch nur für die Wikipeda da? Oder ist da auch schon andere Quellen angezapft worden, oder will man da noch andere Dinge reintun?
Also ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher, in welche Richtung deine Frage ging. Daten aus anderen Quellen zu nehmen, oder Wikidata in anderen Stellen auch zu verwenden?
Na beides, momentan klingt es ja so, also die ursprüngliche Idee war, wir haben die Wikimedia, die ist voll erzeugt, das kann nur Menschen lesen und sonst niemand. Wir bauen jetzt so ein Projekt, das Projekt namen wir Wikidata, was letztlich dazu dient, um die Beziehungen, die in der Wikipedia drinstehen, sozusagen so in Struktur zu organisieren, dass wir sie auch maschinenlesbar haben. Und dann kann man sagen, wenn man das hat, dann kann man das ja vielleicht auch auf andere Themenbereiche anwenden. Oder es gibt vielleicht Leute, die sagen so, Entschuldigung, sie haben da diese semantische Technologie, die ist für uns doch sehr interessant.
Genau so was kriegen wir häufig zu hören, und das freut uns. Ich weiß nicht, bist du schon mal mit Eurowings geflogen?
Hm, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, also die haben, die hießen früher Germanwings, bis was passiert ist und so. Und Eurowings hat so eine App, wo man während des Flugs gucken kann, wo bin ich eigentlich? Und dann wird eine Karte angezeigt und Städte drum herum. Dann kann man auf die Stadt draufklicken, kriegt dann so Informationen zur Stadt. Und wir wussten das gar nicht, aber irgendwann hat uns jemand einen Screenshot geschickt, das da im Impressum von dieser App drin steht. Build with the magic of Wikidata. Das heißt, die benutzen das, um ihre Informationen, die sie da haben, anzureichern und zu verbessern. Das ist eine klassische Anwendung. Es gibt andere Anwendungen, wenn man dann zum Beispiel sagt, hier, ich bin in der Stadt und ich möchte irgendwie Denkmäler um mich herum und die Geschichte von diesen Denkmälern sehen, dann krieg ich dann irgendwie gleich, was ist um mich herum angezeigt und bekomme halt Informationen mit Wikidata gefüttert.
Aber das greift dann dabei wieder auf die Wikipeda zurück, oder?
Nee, das greift auf Wikidata direkt zurück und benutzt diese Information, die in Wikidata drin steht, also mit den Geoinformationen und so weiter. Da steht dann, was, hilf mir mal, es gibt so viele tolle Anwendungen.
Es gibt so viele tolle Anwendungen, in der Tat. Es gibt zum Beispiel noch Libreview, das ist eine Seite, die es dir erlaubt, über alle möglichen Dinge Reviews zu schreiben, unter freien Lizenzen. Also du schreibst dann halt deine Buchrezension vielleicht nicht auf Amazon und gibst sie Amazon, sondern auf dem Projekt. Die benutzen Wikidata, um die Gegenstände, die man reviewen kann, zu identifizieren. Oder Quora, die Frage-Antwort-Seite, die benutzen Wikidata auch, um ihren Themenbaum aufzuräumen.
Und dann gibt es noch den großen Bereich der Original Nerds. Also die Leute, die Nerds waren, bevor Computer entstanden sind. Ich rede von Bibliothekarinnen und Bibliothekarinnen. Das sind Leute, die sich jahrzehntelang mit der Ordnung der Dinge beschäftigt haben. Da gibt es Nationalbibliotheken, da gibt es übergeordnete Register, wie sowas gemacht wird. Es gibt ein Verzeichnis, das nennt sich VIAF, das ist für Personenregister, was Bibliothekare benutzen. Und die sagen irgendwie, hey, es gibt so viele widerstreitende Systeme, wie man jetzt eine Person eindeutig mit einer Nummer bezeichnen kann. Aber es gibt ein System, wo ich das dann im Zweifelsfalle auch selber ändern kann und wo eine Webseite hinter steht, die irgendwie fast jeder kennt, nämlich diese Wikipedia und dann gibt es halt dieses Wikidata. Beziehen wir uns doch darauf. Verknüpfen wir unser Ordnungssystem doch einfach mit Wikidata und haben dann, wenn andere Leute sich auch mit Wikidata verknüpfen, den Vorteil, dass wir das untereinander vergleichen können. Das Ordnungssystem der britischen Nationalbibliothek mit dem der deutschen und so weiter.
Warte mal, das heißt im Prinzip, dieses Wikidata ist nicht eine Technologie, die auch in anderen Fachbereichen verwendet wird, sondern jeder, der sich damit beschäftigt, speist das auch in Wikidata ein. Das heißt, alles Wissen landet dort.
Für den meisten Teil schon, ja. Man kann auch eigene Instanzen von der Software unter Wikidata laufen lassen und diese selber speichern. Es gibt Projekte, die das machen, aber ich glaube, die meisten entscheiden sich doch dafür, die Daten in Wikidata abzulegen, wenn das geht, wenn sie relevant für Wikidata sind.
Das ist genau die Frage, die ich mir stelle. Da ist ja die Frage, ich habe jetzt mal einen Fachbereich, sei es Briefmarken, Modelleisenbahnen, Ameisenbeine, Zählen, was auch immer, und habe einen unheimlichen Wissensschatz, den könnte ich ja im Prinzip in Wikidata auch einspeisen. Dann wäre er auch da, tut niemandem weh.
Das wird auch gemacht, ja.
Aber du hast jetzt gerade Relevanz gesagt.
Wir haben Relevanzkriterien, aber die sind relativ großzügig, denke ich. Was ist es? Es muss ein reales Objekt oder Konzept oder sowas sein. Pokémon? Das ist ein Konzept.
Oh, das ist wirklich...
Du musst Quellen dafür haben, das ist noch relativ wichtig. Du darfst es dir nicht aus den Fingern saugen. Aber wenn du eine gute Quelle für etwas hast, dann darfst du es auch eintragen in Wikidata, auch wenn es jetzt nicht an sich relevant genug ist für Wikipedia selber. Zum Beispiel, wenn du ein komplettes Werksverzeichnis von einem Komponisten hast, die individuellen Kompositionen werden jetzt vielleicht nicht relevant, um alle in einzelnen Wikipedia Artikel zu haben. Aber du kannst gerne für jede einzelne Komposition ein Datenobjekt anlegen, wo steht Komponist, Titel, vielleicht gewidmet, wann wurde das komponiert, in welcher Tonart steht das, wie lange ist das, kannst du alles anlegen.
Es gibt Aktivisten, die sich zum Beispiel mit Open Science, also offenen Wissenschaften beschäftigen und die sagen hier, wäre es nicht toll, wenn wir wirklich suchen könnten, wer hat mit wem ein Paper co geschrieben. Und da dann halt jetzt massiv, das bringt uns dann auch Probleme bei der Skalierbarkeit, aber ist erstmal schöner Aktivismus, massiv da wissenschaftliche Papers reinpumpen oder die Titel und die Autoren von wissenschaftlichen Papers, also die Metadaten über diese wissenschaftlichen Papers, sodass man dann halt auch wirklich mal in so einem Zeitstrahl sehen kann, wann gab es denn das erste Paper zum Zika-Virus, wie hat sich das über die Jahre entwickelt, wann gab es die große Explosion der wissenschaftlichen Forschung zu diesem Fachbegriff, und da kannst du dann halt auch Wissenschaft sozusagen anschaulich sehen, also wie sich das über die Zeit entwickelt hat.
Habt ihr schon mal Themen rausgeworfen, oder wie heißt das, Wissensgegenstände, schon mal Wissensgegenstände entfernt?
Wir sowieso nicht als Angestellte, denn wir sind nicht für den Content zuständig.
Genau, wir machen ja nur die Software, wir sind doch nur einfache Arbeiter im Weinberg des freien Wissens.
Natürlich, natürlich. Aber wurden schon mal Wissensgegenstände entfernt?
Also das macht die Community nach ihren eigenen Regeln, es werden natürlich Dupletten entfernt, Schreibfehler korrigiert und so weiter.
Duplikate werden entfernt, oder wenn jemand zur Werbung ein Datenobjekt für dich selber angelegt hat, kann es schon auch sein, dass es gelöscht wird.
Aber das verstehe ich wiederum nicht, wenn es um das Wissen der Welt geht, dann ist ja mal ganz groß gedacht, wollen wir jeden Menschen darin haben?
Ich glaube nicht, nee. Wieso nicht? Also es ist alles super fuzzy und vielleicht in fünf Jahren reden wir da auch ganz anders drüber, den Anspruch, den wir im Moment haben. Ich weiß, dass ganz viel so, guck mal da hinten, dreikömpfiger Affo und ich erkläre das nicht weiter, aber wir haben ungefähr einen enzyklopedischen Anspruch, was auch immer das heißt. Wir sagen irgendwie, das, was ein Laie über ein Wissensgebiet wissen möchte, auf dem letzten Stand der Forschung so, das ist für uns relevant. Für uns sind super spezielle Sachen nicht relevant, für uns ist nicht jeder Einwohner Deutschlands relevant, sondern muss dann auch irgendwie dann schon mal ein Zeitungsartikel zu dieser Person gegeben haben, weil die irgendwas gemacht hat.
Das ist dann gerade auch wieder das Quellenargument. So ein Zeitungsartikel wäre dann eine Quelle.
Naja, aber das, was ich nicht verstehe ist, also Ziel dieses Projektes ist es ja, das Wissen der Welt zu strukturieren. Und wir haben ja auch gesagt, als Beispiel irgendwie Datenjournalismus. Und natürlich kann ich ganz hervorragend Datenjournalismus über die Bevölkerung eines Landes machen. So, wenn ich aber sage, ich will die Bevölkerung gar nicht drin haben, sondern nur relevant, also was auch immer das heißt sozusagen, ich schließe einfach einen Teil aus. Dann verwehre ich mir ja sozusagen genauso. Und ist das dann, ist das eine Ressourcenfrage? Oder warum?
Also die, einerseits ja, wir wollen dahin, dass wir das Wissen der Menschheit abbilden. Das ist Wikipedias Vision, das ist Wikimedias Vision. Aber gleichzeitig müssen wir das abwägen gegen, können wir das, was wir haben, in einem guten Zustand halten mit den Menschen und Werkzeugen, die wir haben. Und im Moment hat Wikidata eine Freiwilligen Community von etwa 17.000 Menschen, die mindestens einen Edit im Monat machen. Mit denen maintainen wir 37 Millionen Items. Kannst du dir kurz ausrechnen, wie viele Items auf eine Person kommen, die nur mindestens einen Edit machen muss. Und da muss man halt dran arbeiten, indem man einerseits mehr Community aufbaut und der Community bessere Werkzeuge gibt, um mit mehr Daten umgehen zu können.
Ja, mehr Datenschatz und weniger Datenmüllhalte.
Ich finde es spannend, dass man immer noch diesen Punkt stößt, weil es diesen Begriff Big Data gibt. Das einzige Spannende, was ich diesem Konzept finde, ist wirklich zu sagen, lass uns doch einfach mal alles mitnehmen und dann gucken wir hinterher, ob wir damit was anfangen können. Ihr habt ja auch über Bias gesprochen, auch die Trennung zwischen Datenmüll und Datenschatz ist ja auch, man weiß es halt nicht. Man muss es halt erstmal festlegen und hinterher, ob es gerechtfertigt ist, wird man nie erfahren, weil man kann es ja nicht nachprüfen.
Na gut. Das sind super große Fragen und irgendwann ist man dann bei der Metaphysik und wo kommen wir eigentlich hin und so weiter. Das ist im Moment der Zustand, den wir uns haben und das ist auch schon abstrakt und nördig genug so. Wer weiß, vielleicht wird es irgendwann ein Big Data Projekt. Ich glaube es aber nicht. Ich glaube, es geht wirklich. Enzyklopädisches Wissen wird ganz lange so der Treiber bleiben.
Wir reden gleich noch mal darüber, wo es hingehen soll. Vorher gibt es noch eine weitere Ausgabe der NerdNews, die von Mo und vorgetragen werden.
Länderchefs verlängern 7-Tage-Regelung. Öffentlich-rechtliche Sender sollen eigene Beiträge länger als bisher im Internet zur Verfügung stellen können. Außerdem sollen ARD, ZDF und Deutschlandradio mehr Freiheit für ihre redaktionellen Angebote im Internet bekommen. Darauf haben sich die Ministerpräsidenten am Freitag bei einem Treffen in Saarbrücken geeinigt. Gleichzeitig wurden die Sender zu verstärkten Sparbemühungen aufgefordert. Ob es eine neue Frist geben soll, ist unklar. Die alte Bundesregierung hat in den letzten Tagen ihrer Amtszeit auf den EU-Rat eingewirkt, dass große Datennetzbetreiber bis zu sieben Jahre lang von Einschränkungen durch EU-Regulierungen ausgenommen werden. Das kommt vor allem der Deutschen Telekom zugute, die zu einem Drittel im Staatsbesitz ist. Zum Ausgleich dafür sollen die Großunternehmen verpflichtet werden, Mitbewerbern die Beteiligung an Projekten zum Netzausbau zu ermöglichen. Ob eine solche Mitarbeit tatsächlich zustande kommt, soll dabei nicht entscheidend sein. Landgericht Hamburg distanziert sich von eigener Rechtsprechung. Das Hamburger Landgericht hält nicht mehr an seinem strengen Haftungsmaßstab bei Verlinkungen auf Urheberrechtsverletzende Inhalte fest. Im September 2016 entschied der Europäische Gerichtshof, dass der Betreiber einer Webseite für das Setzen eines Links auf urheberrechtlich geschützte Werke haften kann, wenn der Link mit der Absicht gesetzt wurde, Gewinn zu erzielen. Vom Linksetzenden wird erwartet, dass er nachprüft, dass das betroffene Werk nicht unbefugt veröffentlicht wurde. Wie dies in der Praxis umgesetzt werden soll, ließ der EUGH offen. Kurz danach bestätigte das Landgericht Hamburg die Linie in einem Beschluss. Wie jetzt bekannt wurde, änderte das Landgericht in einem weiteren Beschluss ein halbes Jahr später seine Auffassung. Eine Nachprüfung sei bei gewerblicher Linksetzung in der Regel nicht zumutbar.
Die Inhalte hier sind auf jeden Fall befugt veröffentlicht, unter anderem auch die Creative Commons Musik vom Chiptunes gleich Win Sampler. Und der Song, den wir jetzt noch hören, ist von Purely Grey und heißt Sunset Bridge. So, und damit haben wir beim Chaos Radio 240 bei Wikidata noch eine halbe Stunde, wo wir uns einerseits mal mit den Plänen zur Zukunft beschäftigen und andererseits hat Lukas während der Songs gerade gesagt, hier, ich habe da noch was, was hast du denn da noch?
Also was ich hatte, war eine Idee.
Ja.
Ich könnte ja mal die, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die richtig heißen, auch die Niederlassung oder so, Lokalveranstaltungen vom CCC in Deutschland suchen, aber hat sich dann rausgestellt, dafür haben wir offenbar noch keine Daten auf Wikidata. Es gibt kein Datenobjekt für den CCC. Hier nicht für den Entropia in Chaosruhe. Das sind die zwei, die ich kenne. Also offenbar haben wir da nicht so große Abdeckung. Aber Lydia hat dann gemeint, man könnte ja zumindest nach Hacker Spaces generell suchen. Und da hat sich rausgestellt, hatten wir, ich glaube, 13 Stück insgesamt, davon drei in den USA, jeweils zwei in Deutschland und im Vereinigten Königreich und noch einen in Österreich.
Da hast du aber noch, also da geht noch was, oder?
Das wäre jetzt die Aufforderung an euch, damit zu helfen.
Ich habe gerade ausverkündigt, ich bin ein Wissensgegenstand. Wie fühlst du dich? Da steht, ich bin ein Mensch. Schon mal gut, ich kenne Leute, die zweifeln das an. Ich sei männlich, Deutsch, Vorname, sei im 20. Jahrhundert geboren und eine Radio-Personality. Immerhin, mein Twitter-Name steht auch drin. Wer macht sowas, oder wird das automatisch angelegt, wenn es irgendwie Wikipedia integriert?
Kannst du nachgucken?
Wie?
Das ist ein Wiki, das heißt, es gibt eine Versionsgeschichte und auch Diskussionsseiten, wenn man sich unterhalten will. Aber in der Versionsgeschichte kann man nachschauen, wer eine Bearbeitung gemacht hat.
Okay, das ist jetzt für die Sendung völlig illere Wand.
Aber wie fühlt man sich so als Wissensgegenstand?
Also gerade, wo ihr jetzt auch gesagt habt Relevanz, und dann nehmt ihr so, aha, ich bin halt so relevant, okay, whatever.
Naja, aber noch mal auf die Hacker-Spaces, Leute, das geht so nicht. Also 13 Hacker-Spaces, das kann doch nicht sein, dass Pokemon komplett in Wikidata drin ist und die Hacker-Spaces nur 13 Stück.
Aber das ist eigentlich auch ein geiles Argument für alles. Es kann doch nicht sein, dass Pokemon komplett drin ist und die Werke von Beethoven nicht. Oder Tageszeitung oder was auch immer. Noch etwas, was wir rausfinden können, wollen? Nein? Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen in Zukunft noch geplant? Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen hin und her verwirrt worden. Das ist alles ganz superschwierig und da gibt es ganz viele verschiedene Sachen. Jetzt denke ich, eigentlich ist das ja auch fertig irgendwie. Es gibt jetzt diese Wissensstrukturen, da kann man auch neu definieren, wenn man die braucht. Aber im Prinzip geht es jetzt darum, das irgendwie aufzuarbeiten, ist eigentlich alles schön. Von hier bis fertig, wo seid ihr gerade?
Also, es gibt noch eine ganze Menge zu tun. Das, was wir jetzt haben, kann schon eine ganze Menge, aber man kann ziemlich coole Sachen damit machen. Aber da geht noch was, zum Beispiel, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt hatte, bessere Werkzeuge bauen, um Datenqualität zu sichern und mit mehr Daten umgehen zu können. Das ist ein großes Thema, an dem Lukas zum Beispiel arbeitet. Vielleicht willst du da was dazu erzählen.
Die Menge der Daten, die bearbeitet werden, kann es beschränkt?
Es gibt keine feste Grenze in dem Sinne, aber...
Menschen skalieren nicht so gut. Die meisten brauchen irgendwie bis zu acht Stunden Schlaf pro Nacht, in denen sie nicht in Wikidata editieren können.
Ich dachte, dafür gibt es Mate?
Ja, richtig. Aber wenn dann halt irgendwie Mate Notstand ist...
Okay, verstehe.
Also es ist, wir, es sollen mehr Daten dann halt auch sinnvoll bearbeitet werden können, dass man sieht, okay, da ist irgendwie gerade bei einer Menge von Daten was falsch. Wie kann ich auf einen Schlag was machen? Lukas, erzähl doch einfach mal.
Genau. Also das Datenmodell von Wikidata ist ja sehr flexibel. Es gibt wirklich nur diese Verbindung zwischen Datenobjekten. Es hindert mich niemand daran zu sagen, Berlin liegt in dem Land und jetzt sage ich nicht Deutschland, sondern ich sage Tisch, das Abstrakte Konzept Tisch. Oder ich sage, der Bürgermeister von Berlin ist jetzt der Atlantische Ozean. Also lauter Sachen sind alles einfach Datenobjekte und Wikidata kümmern sich da jetzt erstmal nicht darum, was es für einen Sinn ergibt. Aber natürlich kann man doch schon sagen, auch wenn es Ausnahmen gibt, zum Beispiel Städte, die Katzen zu ihren Bürgermeistern wählen, kann man sagen, meistens sollte jetzt der Bürgermeister ein Mensch sein und jemand, der ein Geburtsdatum hat, sollte auch ein Mensch sein oder generell ein Lebewesen oder ein fiktives Lebewesen. Aber eine Stadt hat zum Beispiel kein Geburtsdatum, sondern ein Gründungsdatum. Und solche Konsistenzprüfungen und Prüfungen, ob die Daten Sinn ergeben, kann man schon definieren und kann man eben, weil die ganzen Daten so maschineliesbar sind, kann man auch superautomatisch durchführen und daran arbeite ich eben.
Aber gerade bei Berlin, vielleicht gibt es ja noch einen Berlin in Katalonien oder wo auch immer. Und wie wird das zu sagen, da hat man aber so zwei Berlins, beide sind ganz was anderes.
Wir haben mehrere Berlins, also es gibt halt Berlin, dieses hier, es gibt dann in Massachusetts, es gibt Berlin, ein Album von Lurit, also die heißen alle Berlin auf Deutsch oder auf Englisch Berlin. Die haben aber alle unterschiedliche Q-Nummern. Deswegen diese Sache.
Das heißt fürs System ist es egal, aber ich muss sagen, diese Regelnachprüfung muss ja schon auf, also der erste Impuls wäre so, Berlin ist kein Album, das ist doch Quatsch.
Die ganze Datelverknüpfung passiert ja nur auf Basis von diesen Q-Nummern.
Ja, ich meine bei den Prüfungsalgorithmen.
Da läuft es genauso, die kommen da eigentlich nicht wirklich durcheinander.
Na es gibt einen Wissensgegenstand, der bezeichnet Berlin die Stadt in Deutschland und einen anderen, der bezeichnet das Musikalbum. Und bei dem einen steht irgendwie ist ein Musikalbum, bei dem anderen steht ist eine Stadt.
Ach so, also das prüfe ich nicht nach, sondern ich sage dann, also wenn es eine Stadt ist, dann hat es aber auch keinen...
Ganz genau.
Also wenn jetzt ein menschlicher Editor verwirrt ist und bei Berlin und das Item Berlin das Album als Hauptstadt irgendwo einträgt, weil er nur das Berlin gesehen hat und nicht nachgeschaut hat, worauf bezieht sich es jetzt, dann können wir aber merken, Moment mal, die Hauptstadt sollte aber eine Stadt sein, das hier ist ein Musikalbum und was wir in Zukunft sogar noch besser machen könnten, was wir aktuell glaube ich nicht vorhaben, wäre aber zum Beispiel dann sogar vorzuschlagen, meinst du nicht dieses andere Datenobjekt, was so ähnlich ist, aber sinnvoller erscheint? Dann kann das der gleiche oder ein anderer menschlicher Editor nochmal anschauen und entscheiden, ja das macht so Sinn, dann ändere ich das jetzt.
Okay. Genau, das ist so ein großes Themenkomplex, an dem wir arbeiten. Ein anderes große Themenkomplex ist strukturierte Daten für Wikimedia Commons. Wikimedia Commons ist das Medienarchiv für Wikimedia. Das heißt, da speichern wir Bilder, Videos, PDF-Dateien und so weiter für Wikipedia und all die anderen Projekte.
Genau, also wenn du ein Wikipedia-Artikel aufrufst und da ist ein Bild drin, kommt das wahrscheinlich von Commons. Genau, das ist unser Medienarchiv.
Und das hat genau dasselbe Problem wie Wikipedia. Die Bilder, Videos und so weiter, da sind nicht ganz Freitext, aber wieder nicht maschinenlesbar beschrieben. Das heißt, ich habe ein Bild von einer Katze, von einem Baum, dann steht da vielleicht als menschenlesbarer Text, Katze vor einem Baum, aber wenn ich jetzt suche, nach Katzen vor Bäumen, wird es schwierig. Und da arbeiten wir dran, genau das wieder maschinenlesbar zu machen und damit all die Bilder, all die Schätze, die in Wikimedia Commons vergraben sind im Moment, weil man sie halt nicht findet, zu heben.
Und wenn das Bild heißt Katze vor einem Baum, und das ist auf Deutsch der Titel, dann habe ich ja nochmal Glück gehabt, wenn es irgendwie Kat in front of tree ist, dann wahrscheinlich auch noch das, während das zweite was mir einfällt. Ey, was ist, wenn das auf Chinesisch ist? Ich wüsste ja noch nicht mal, wie ich das eintippen soll. Und wenn du dann einfach sagen willst, ich suche aber ganz dringend Bilder von einer Katze vom Baum, Grundfarbe grün, unter der CC-Lizenz CC by SA Version 4, aus den Jahren 89 bis 2003. Wenn ich das irgendwie in die Suche eingeben kann, das geht nur, wenn die Metadaten von den Bildern strukturiert abgelegt worden sind in einer strukturierten Datenbank. Dann haben wir einfach die Technologie von Wikidata genommen und das dann auf dieses Medienarchiv zu machen. Das heißt, ich kann wirklich nicht nur über die Wissensgegenstände in der Welt, sondern ich kann dann auch über die Medien, die es dann gibt, in diesem Medienarchiv strukturierte Abfragen machen und sagen, wie viele Bilder gibt es eigentlich in Commons, wo Katzen drauf sind.
Aber das ist sozusagen eine eigene Instanz, eine eigene Wikidata Instanz? Das hat nichts mit der Weltwissensliste zu tun.
Genau, das ist eine eigene Instanz. Dieses Commons bekommt einfach die Technologie von Wikidata spendiert und läuft dann anders. Genau, und dann haben wir halt zwei große Sachen. Einmal Wissensgegenstände, Bilder und Töne und so weiter, die man semantisch auszeichnen und durchsuchen kann. Dann fehlt eigentlich nur noch das, was den Menschen eigentlich zum Menschen macht, also wo das Denken eigentlich anfängt. Die Sprache. Wenn man die jetzt auch noch mal semantisch aufbereiten und durchsuchen könnte, wie geil wäre das denn?
Jetzt kriege ich gerade einen Knoten im Gehirn, wie kann sowas aussehen?
Wie ein Wetterbuch. Also im Duden hast du zum Beispiel Tisch, ist ein Substantiv und wird so und so gebeugt, all das. Und wenn du das in strukturierter Form vorliegen hast, dann noch mit Übersetzungen in andere Sprachen, dann kannst du das für ganz viele Dinge benutzen. Zum Beispiel automatische Textgenerierung, automatische Übersetzung, Sprachforschung, all diese Dinge.
Ich habe dann ein Wörterbuch, was Menschen und Maschinen lesbar ist. Übersprachlich angelegt, weil ich die Technologie von Wikidata benutze, halte ich fest, also ich sehe, du sitzt bequem deswegen. Also es wird jetzt mal abgefangen in 300 Sprachen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwo auf der Welt ein Wörterbuch gibt, maltesisch-estnisch. Ich glaube, der Markt ist sehr klein. Das könnten wir mit strukturierten Daten für Wiktionary, mit Wikidata für Wiktionary, könnten wir sowas schaffen. Also wir könnten beliebige Sprachkombinationen als Wörterbuch, maschinen- und menschenlesbar, quasi erstellen. Das heißt, du hast einen Text, du kannst dann gleich sehen, okay, dieses Wort, diese grammatische Funktion, willst du zu diesem Wort auch noch die Bedeutung haben? Und hier ist der Wikipedia Artikel und das wissen wir doch über uns. So groß ist der Bürgermeister in dieser Stadt und so weiter. Das alles in maschinenlesbar, verknüpftbar, unendlich remixbar. Ja, abgefahren ist das denn.
Klingt gut, aber ich muss ja fragen, funktioniert das perfekt oder ist das dann sozusagen nur, also weil zu übersetzen ist ja immer so eine Sache. Also es gibt eine wörtliche Übersetzung, dann gibt es sagen der Kontext einer Besetzung. Kann das dabei auch helfen oder?
Auf jeden Fall, denn genau diese Verwendung von Wörtern in unterschiedlichem Kontext, in unterschiedlichen Bedeutungen, ist das jetzt eher ein formal genutztes Wort oder eins, das ich in der Bar mit einem Kumpel benutze und so. Das sind genau die Dinge, die wir dann auch festhalten wollen und die so wichtig sind für automatische Übersetzungen zum Beispiel. Denn wenn ich nicht weiß, ob Worte Kolokialism ist oder nicht, kann bei der Übersetzung ganz schön viel schiefgehen.
Man lästet auch gerne über automatische Übersetzungen, da sieht man auch noch einiges zu machen, aber Google Translate funktioniert schon erschreckend gut zum Teil. Er hat den Nachteil, es ist Google Translate, das heißt arbeitet auf einer Basis, die mir erstmal nicht zugänglich wäre. Mit Wikidata für Wiktionary hätte ich dann halt auf einen Schlag, Bäm, millionenfach eine freie zugängliche linguistische Datenbasis, wo ich dann automatische Übersetzungsprogramme drauf aufsetzen könnte, wo halt nicht irgendwie Google den Daumen drauf hält, sondern wir alle.
Wird daran gearbeitet, ist das momentan so eine fixe Idee? Also die geil klingt, aber wo man noch nicht dran sitzt?
Da sitzen wir aktiv dran an der Entwicklung der Infrastruktur dafür.
Wer ist jetzt, seit ihr drei Leute das, wie ihr hier auf dem Sofa sitzt, und dann noch der eine Werkstudent irgendwie oder vor allen Dingen ist das nur Deutschland oder hat Wikimedia in verschiedenen Nationen Teams, die auch an Wikidata arbeiten, oder wie läuft das?
Also die Softwareentwicklung an Wikidata läuft tatsächlich hauptsächlich bei Wikimedia Deutschland ab. Für die strukturierten Daten auf Commons ist jetzt tatsächlich die Wikimedia Foundation in den USA zuständig und die machen dafür die Softwareentwicklung. Und wir unterstützen sie, glaube ich, dabei. Und aktuell sind wir eher dabei an diesen strukturierten Daten für Wiktionary, an dem Wörterbuch Daten eben. Das ist das, worauf wir uns gerade konzentrieren. Wir sind dabei die Softwareentwicklung von Wikimedia Deutschland mit, wie viele Leute?
Dutzend. Die, die an Wikidata arbeiten, so um die zehn.
Zehn Leute, die programmieren und so. Die ganze Softwareentwicklung ist ein bisschen größer. 25.
Und was ist denn so dein ganz konkretes nächstes Feature? Also klar, wir hätten gerne so Wiktionary, Wikidata und so, aber was passiert morgen oder übermorgen?
Übermorgen gibt es eine Konferenz. Wir haben uns gedacht, nach fünf Jahren Wikidata kann man ja auch mal eine internationale Konferenz zum Thema machen und wir laden alle...
Und kann man feiern?
Genau, kann man feiern, den Geburtstag. Wir laden halt Leute aus der ganzen Welt ein. Wir haben gedacht, das ist so ein nördiges Thema, mehr als 200 Leute kommen bestimmt nicht, zack, war alles ausverkauft. Im Moment ist es nicht möglich, da jetzt noch ein Ticket zu kriegen. Aber die Leute, die das Video-Streaming beim CCC machen und so weiter...
Und du meinst jetzt gerade hier das machen?
Zum Beispiel, genau die. Die werden uns aber bei der Konferenz helfen. Das heißt, man kann zumindest die Vorträge dann noch mal live im Netz sehen. Vor Ort im Tagesspiegel, ist leider ausverkauft und da ist irgendwie die Grenze so. Aber man wird das alles im Netz sehen können. Und da gibt es halt Leute, die sich beschäftigen mit... Ich arbeite in einem Museum und möchte diese ganzen Kunstgegenstände, die ich da habe, in Wikidata reinbringen. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, wie kann ich Wikidata in der Erziehung einsetzen? Wie kann Wikidata für Politik eingesetzt werden? Also politische Daten, da irgendwie Journalismus drüber machen. Es gibt Leute, die beschäftigen sich dann nur mit Ontologien, also mit der philosophischen Lehre von der Ordnung der Dinge. Es gibt ganz viele technische Sachen, wie kann ich das und das programmieren. Es gibt die ganze Zeit irgendwie einen Ort, wo man Abfragen dann selber erstellen kann. Und am Sonntag feiern wir dann halt den fünften Geburtstag. Und dann gibt es Geschenke für Wikidata. Das ganze Jahr haben Leute neue Features programmiert und die werden dann ausgepackt und gezeigt.
Wir haben ja zwei, die schon öffentlich sind. Na gut, das eine ist jetzt sehr technisch. Das andere ist eine deutlich verbesserte Suchfunktion. Die alte Suchfunktion auf Wikidata hat hauptsächlich auf dem Artikel Text operiert, der halt in unserem Fall nicht Text ist, sondern etwas, was der Mensch nie zu Gesicht bekommt. Der bekommt die strukturierten Daten zu Gesicht. Und jetzt haben wir eben eine neue Suchfunktion, mit der ich mich nicht wirklich auskenne, aber sie funktioniert auf jeden Fall deutlich besser. Die Ergebnisse sind relativ viel weiter. Wenn ich nach Berlin suche, kriege ich dann zum Beispiel als erstes die Hauptstadt und nicht das Album oder die Stadt in Minnesota oder wo auch immer das war.
Okay, ich habe gerade ein totales Déjà-vu. Ich glaube, irgendwie die Verbesserung der Suchfunktion scheint bei vielen Projekten ein gutes Ding zu sein.
Na ja, immer die Suche muss besser werden, die Eingabe muss benutzerfreundlicher werden. Irgendwann sind wir auch da.
Hilft alles nicht. Zum Abschluss, weil ja nicht nur die hier sitzt seit Nerds, sondern auch viele von den Menschen, die vor dem neuartigen Grundfunk-Opfangskrieg sitzen, sondern das vielleicht jetzt gerade hören, sind Nerds oder möchten gerne welche werden. Welche Art von Hilfe kann man euch denn zugutekommen lassen, wenn man das Projekt Total Teufel in die Winde, da möchte ich auch was tun, außer Hacker-Spaces eintragen. Das hatten wir ja schon gesagt.
Genau, also weniger Hilfe brauchen wir bei Pokémon. Der Datensatz ist vollständig. Weiß nicht, ob ich das bereits erwähnte. Nein, also sucht euch irgendwie ein Thema aus. Das können Barockkirchen in Oberbayern sein, die ihr dann vervollständigt einfach. Das wäre so eine Sache. Also die meisten fangen auch einfach damit an, dass wir einfach mal gucken, wir haben eine tolle Funktion around me. Und dann sieht man einfach Wissensgegenstände um die jetzige Position.
Auch Pokémon?
Also was weiß ich, irgendwelche Bauern decken umher herum. Und da fehlen dann vielleicht auch noch mal Daten, die man nachtragen kann. Manchmal fehlt ein Foto, das man noch eintragen kann.
Aber ist es die Hilfe, die ihr braucht, nur die Vervollständigung des Datensatzes? Oder kann man auch sagen, ich gucke mal euren Quellcode an, mache Qualitätsmanagement oder programmiere ein neues Feature?
Auf jeden Fall. Also wer mit coden will, gerne. Sowohl an der Software selbst, aber auch Tools bauen, die unsere Daten benutzen. In andere Tools integrieren. Wir hatten vor kurzem zum Beispiel ein Programm, wie hieß es, Bear Tunes?
Genau, das ist ein Apple Programm, wo man halt irgendwie seine Musiksammlung durchsuchen kann und dann halt irgendwie so Playlisten zusammenstellen kann mit nach der und der Stimmung und so. Und eine der Quellen, wo diese Playlist-Übersichtsintelligenz-Maschine damit gefüttert war, war dann halt Wikidata. Das ist ein kommerzielles Programm, aber das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Also ihr müsst nicht unbedingt freie Software schaffen. Ihr könnt Wikidata immer benutzen. Das ist vielleicht noch was, was man noch extra erwähnen soll. Also Wikipedia ist unter einer freien Lizenz Weitergabe unter gleichen Bedingungen oder so verfügbar. Weil Wikidata ist es eigentlich die radikalsmögliche Option. Das heißt CC0, Public Domain, keine Angabe der Quelle ist notwendig. Das ist manchmal einfach pragmatischer. Du kannst nicht in deiner App sagen, diese Temperatur wurde ihnen präsentiert von. Also für jedes kleine einzelne Datum kannst du nicht eine Quelle angeben. Außerdem ist es so, dass einzelne Fakten eigentlich nicht unter das Urheberrecht fallen. Also ich kann nicht sagen, ich habe durch die Schöpfung meines Genius herausgefunden, dass Goethe die und die Körpergrößerte oder so. Das ist dann einfach Allgemeinwissen und es fällt nicht unter das Urheberrecht. Und das dritte ist, dass wir sagen, wir machen CC0, wir machen Public Domain, das ist auch eine wichtige Art, dass es dann einfach alle nachnutzen können, kommerziell und nicht kommerziell.
Das ist korrekt. Wir freuen uns natürlich über jeden, der Wikidata benutzt. Wir freuen uns aber noch mehr über jeden, der Wikidata benutzt und es sagt, dass er Wikidata benutzt. Und noch mehr über jeden, der es sagt und Freisoftware produziert.
Okay, ich habe jetzt noch eine allerletzte Frage an euch. Das heißt also, man kann diesen Daten dazu nutzen, man kann damit machen, was man will, und man kann sie auch als Grundlage für neue intelligente Technologien benutzen. Gibt es irgendeine Art und Weise, dass ihr sichergestellt habt, dass nicht die Skynet Technologie den Terminator bringen wird, auf Grund von Wikidata entsteht? Oder müssen wir damit einfach rechnen?
Also, ich mache mir da nicht so viele Sorgen. Ich denke, wenn der Moment kommt, dass Wikidata ein eigenes Bewusstsein entwickelt und sich zur Skynet weiterentwickelt, wird es sich schon daran erinnern, wer dann von Anfang an dabei war und die ersten Zahlen mit programmiert hat. Und dann, denke ich mal, begrüße ich dann auch unsere Maschinenherrscher entsprechend und rechne mir da gute Karrierechancen in der neuen Weltordnung.
Wikidata, ein tolles Projekt, damit möchte ich in Erinnerung bleiben. Und bedanke mich recht herzlich bei Jens, Lydia und Lukas für einen Einblick in dieses Projekt, das das Weltwissen möglicherweise auf eine Art und Weise darstellt, dass auch Maschinen etwas damit anfangen können. Die Links dazu wird es in den Shownotes zur Sendung geben. Danke, dass ihr hier wart.
Danke, dass wir hier sein durften.
Danke, sehr gerne. Vielen Dank, liebes Publikum, dass ihr aufmerksam und gespannt zugehört habt. Und das war das Chaosradio 240. Es wird höchstwahrscheinlich eine relativ hilfreiche Information, die ich also gleich gebe, das nächste Chaosradio auch in Berlin stattfinden. Wir arbeiten gerade dran, dass wir auch die Sendung bei Fritz hier aus der Berlin, Hauptstadt, Deutschland machen können. Genau Informationen am besten über den Twitter-Account verfolgen. Da wird es dann genaueres geben. Jetzt erstmal noch eine letzte Nachricht von mir, Marcus Richter, instance of human, wie ich heute gelernt habe. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
And how many 40s they smoke.